I have to see one more bad movie I'm
gonna poop out crap
Chris
Morgan Freeman that's right son Morgan
Freeman your movies are awesome thank
you so it's on your mind Morgan Freeman
the question is what's on your mind son
well I just saw a crap movie or moving
The Last Airbender or four saga huh
don't even get me started on vampire
suck you can see the future is that why
all your movies are good yes so you
hated the movie yes I personally feel
like being crapped on by a rhinoceros
would be more fun and what are you gonna
do about it
you have to spell it out for them these
days
you used to do something for people
something everyone liked you were a
movie critic some people said you were
the best you were almost a YouTube
partner
have you forgotten you have the power to
save people from movies like The Last
Airbender you know what you must do